it's great to welcome back to the
program frank mink frank is the former
neo-nazi who was misidentified or i
guess who i was misidentified ads on CNN
Headline News dr. Drew's show several
years ago that's how Frank and I got in
touch and he's been on the program a
number of times we've talked about his
autobiography recovering skinhead we've
talked about so many different aspects
of what we're seeing now in terms of the
resurgence of some of these white
supremacists and white nationalist
groups Frank it's been a crazy couple of
weeks within the white supremacist white
nationalist movement when you saw in the
wake of the Charlottesville Virginia
incident Donald Trump talking about
there's fine people on both sides
etcetera were there indirect signals
being sent to some of the groups that
you used to be a part of I mean he he
bow if I was a head of the group when I
was I was the head of the group now and
that would happen like that I mean what
about your the President of the United
States just validated us by saying we
are good people and we are good you know
what what we stand for is good the
Friday night those guys marched and
we're saying the Jews can't replace us
the whole group of them the whole group
of them that are good people now I I do
go on the fact that there are good
people in all human beings and we have
the chance to find them but we have to
at least identify the problem own the
problem and then we can fix it I mean
he's saying that these guys are good
people in the night before they're all
chanting the Jews won't replace us the
Jews he talks a little bit about how in
2008 when President Obama was elected we
know about the resurgence in a lot of
these groups and it's pretty easy to
understand why half black man elected
president you're gonna see a resurgence
in some of these white supremacist white
nationalist neo-nazi groups however
throughout the Obama presidency some of
them sort of started to Peter out a
little bit and then the Trump campaign
happened and the signals being sent to
many of these groups from your contacts
are these groups really experiencing a
strong resurgence right now oh
absolutely
this is this is the this
their new golden age way just like the
early nineties was early nineteen was
the Golden Age of the neo-nazis it's
when the neo-nazis broke away from the
old regime of the Klan and all those you
know and we had a that's when I was in
it and we being this great we resurgent
then and then we they went away you know
they went away until 2008 in 2008 the
numbers grew instantly from election day
and to them now we could say half black
half white - that means a hundred
percent not white of course so but you
got to know that they went dormant for
eight years they got a big number at a
big spike but everything they kept
saying was going to happen didn't happen
Obama didn't come for their guns he
didn't come for the further wives he
didn't come you know all these things
that they said he didn't do it so the
group does kind of went more and more
back to sleep but they still kept their
numbers and he still had these huge
message boards well when Trump comes
along he's using all these campaign
slogans and speeches that are right up
their alley
it just it starts to wake them up
they're like oh yeah we can get behind
this you know and Frank is a guy isn't
given given that you were part of these
groups historically can you tell us
really specifically which slogans or
phrases are the ones that Trump uses
that if you are part of a neo-nazi white
supremacist or white separatist group
you recognize the day he announces for
his real cannon see he says they come
over here they're drug dealers murderers
rapists and I'll assume some of them are
good people right right there he had all
of them that's the day he had all every
one of them I mean cuz that's the same
thing they all step I think I said
there's always races who make exception
there was good I hate all black people
except for John I know John he's cool
they work with him we all all races have
to make exceptions to live in this
country just do he right there just back
that whole thing up because some
Mexicans are okay or some South
Americans they're okay but most of them
are rapists drug dealing gang thug
you know criminals and it's completely
the opposite way of course what's
another example of the the phrasing that
Trump has used which knowingly or not
knowingly I mean I genuinely have no
idea not that it matters
is a sort of signal to white
supremacists a permit of action he
talked about that probably probably
about three four weeks into real
campaigning start talking about the
affirmative action thing which so many
misinformed people and I was one of them
back then about what this really is and
so he you know we should all just be
taking on our merit we don't need a
program to help them get you know
because obviously they didn't start to
race later than we did in this thing but
anyway so when he starts talking about
affirmative action is another big sign
that he's on their side and now if you
have the facts and I know you do about
affirmative action it isn't this you
know you have to take this guy over a
white guy it's that we have to get
people in the great cases the one in
California with the fire department they
they had made it firm of actually come
in and start taking some black guys on
to this force and everyone's like why
should I make a guy who's a less
qualified would be the guy who up saved
my life in a fire now granted there is
no lineage of fire departments or fire
fighters that were black in that area so
now we're trying to change that and
that's they don't get that type of stuff
you know they don't get they think
here's a nice rise to say back in the
day my recruiting days why I didn't grow
up special I grew apart as then being
one I didn't have a silver spoon in my
mouth why should anyone else get above
me
well because see I can hide that in a
job interview a black dude can't hide
he's black turd you know so that was the
facts that I knew and started to change
my views but I heard Donald saying the
same things I used to say when I was not
as informed that is throw up the rally
hey Frank I want to talk a little bit
about how you were sort of pulled into
this entire there's fine people and bad
people on both sides thing you were
brought on to remind me which Fox News
program it was just a Martha mark on the
counter right I believe it is just for
my courage you know tremendous person
unbelievable person but listen here's
the thing to happen
they changed the host on the day of the
interview you were brought on to this
program and you were told that you were
being brought on why and to talk about
what I was being brought on to help talk
to people that are in the
all right about why you know the
alt-right could be bad and why the
alright is different than just the
conservative groups right so I'm like
kind of touch you with this as it is and
so that's why I was brought on to
explain why people are so joining the
alright right now that's right and of
course you're you're positioned as
someone who understands some aspects of
the ideology that is in the out right
through your history in the white
supremacist movement neo-nazi moves etc
you show up there and what happens
during the interview okay I guess that
up one more part where he said I told
them and this was been my thing I've
been staying on standing on all last few
weeks is when I was a neo-nazi I would
marching these rallies and I said this
on your show before and people would
throw bottles at us the antithesis all
these groups they throw bottles at us I
never ducked about almost like whoa I'm
when do I got to rethink my beliefs here
again never did that doesn't work right
so I was that was kind of my key thing
like we don't need more violence against
these guys it's not working it's what
they want so that's what I was going
along to say okay they bring me they
have a guy who was a former you know an
tiffith member and he still was actually
part of the group and he's a he's pretty
cool guy actually so I didn't even know
that until I get on the show they text
me and say oh here's another guest is
gonna be on a book about don't have time
they're really google-owned will come up
and they get him on and he comes right
at me because they kind of told him I
was against him okay so let's slow just
to make sure your audience knows what
you're saying as far as you knew until
right before this appearance you were
going to be the only guest during this
segment and just before the interview
takes place you're told there's a former
and Tifa guy or current auntie Fekkai
former former now tries tries to get
them out they leave aunt Eva okay and so
then during the interview you're put in
this position to what criticize and Tifa
yeah yeah you can see they keep trying
to set up these questions to me to where
it's like it's alright that's what the
question is formed and so when I get
into it with them well not with him but
with the Fox News person I'm just like
well no they there are on organized I
kept saying when you know that my
comments kept starting with well he's
correct on the other he he's not he's
making a good point they kept saying
stuff like that you know
about the antipas guy so I kept doing
that until the end when they finally I
give this tell that they weren't gonna
let me talk about what they brought me
on to talk about and then at the end if
you see that's where I start saying
these guys they do property damage the
the police and the FBI aren't looking at
them for major violent crimes they're
still looking at the neo-nazis and the
right and that's what all right so do
you think the idea here was the
underlying motive to try to again push
this narrative that in the same way that
we can say well Trump said there's good
people on both sides they were trying to
create a situation of drawing an
equivalency between the bad people on
the neo-nazi side and the bad people on
the anti facade is that sort of the
false balance they were trying to create
absolutely because for two days up until
that point the story it started to turn
for them that they had started at the
left had started the fight now so so now
Fox is running with it
and I you know and they were really
running with it and I thought that
Martha would have been different that's
why I kind of agreed to the show
because I really don't want to go on Fox
News that much Alistair let me talk
about Fox News and or not and so because
Fox News has been a huge part of the
campaign which kept backing up the
narrative but Trump was saying which
helps was helping the growth of these
groups and they know that they know that
what happened after the fact that you
have communication with producers
standing over to you where she's like
we're so I'm so sorry I didn't mean for
you to get set up and you know I am not
that type of producer you work at Fox
News you probably article well the chef
guarding because if the producer didn't
who set up that who set up the segment
right isn't it the producers that set it
up and then she told me that she took
off that day her and Martha but I feel I
don't know I just felt really weird and
they just broke backed off in and I had
no contact until they tell me who's my
other guest is and then it's some other
producer and I don't know who they are
and then the show starts and it was
brutally horrible and the segment
supposed to be five minutes and it was
three because I wasn't saying anything
anymore I'm not gonna feed into it to be
on TV I mean oh really you know I'd
rather be coaching hockey so well we
will link to that segment and that's an
incredible
and as always frank mink former neo-nazi
of course his autobiography recovering
skinhead always great to talk to you
Frankie absolutely your audience oppose
me I looked at some of the things last
night so I thought you should have your
mom work you should listen to your
audience sometimes hey you're back
because of that you're back because of
that alright Frank thanks very much
thanks guys see it